this is it don't you die on me don't
count on
it if this whole thing ended there were
only two pilots left up in the air it'll
be me and it'll be You Buck today the
eth will be sending up three task forces
that's the largest AR Moor ever
assembled in the history of mankind
masters of the air is about a group of
American Airmen who did what was asked
of them going FY hang on guys despite
the chances they were either going to
get killed wounded or captured I had
thought there would be easy to be in the
sky a crew fck ahead there's dangers
that you don't really think about
there's more chance of you dying up
there than if you were down in the
trenches these daylight missions just so
sad in the face of unimaginable Mayhem
fighs 12:00 you have 10 guys open fire
let him have it in a machine trying to
keep it in the air any he device try to
stay
alive yes sir when you're in combat you
know who you're fighting for the guy to
your left and the guy to your right they
have nothing but each other and they are
able to conquer anything when they stay
together come on I'm pretty sure that
this is the biggest production any of us
have ever done definitely the hardest
mission accomplished boys but this has
been my dream to do something like this
let alone with the team that made banded
Brothers in the Pacific wo
and getting to bring life to these
heroic men realizing how dangerous it
was and The Bravery with which they
bought our freedom that's the privilege
for me and I hope that that's what an
audience
[Music]
receives